[Music]
there's really only one thing that
pretty much everybody in washington
agrees on and that is our borders don't
matter at all but ukraine's borders are
holy and therefore the government of
ukraine the authoritarian government of
ukraine needs tens of billions of
dollars from u.s taxpayers immediately
stop complaining and by the way
indefinitely
forever
both parties in washington agree with
this
it's the single most important priority
for the country but every poll shows
that actually it's not
the number one issue for americans the
number one issue for actual americans is
inflation so yesterday the president of
ukraine zielenski was asked about the
inflation that the funding of his
country is causing here and his response
was this and we're quoting
inflation is nothing who is thinking
about inflation these things are
secondary
really maybe to you
mr zielinski
but to americans they're actually kind
of meaningful because our countries are
not the same why don't you run yours
we'll run ours
so ukrainian leaders are really not
hiding it anymore they have total
contempt for us they just want our money
they don't care about the united states
even a little bit this is not democracy
is uniting in solidarity this is a scam
every other week zelinski has appeared
in public you may have noticed this with
u.s politicians on hand snuggling with
lindsey graham once again
it's kind of weird that he never seems
worried about his own safety since this
is a war zone he's met with a ton of
hollywood celebrities here he's with ben
stiller
hello
really nice to meet you hello thanks for
taking the time
for me to know yeah we know you you are
well um it's a great honor for me and
nice to see you
um
it's really wonderful you're my hero
as as
you quit a great acting career for this
not so great
but what you've done in the way that
you've
rallied the country and what you know
for the world it's really
inspiring yeah you've really you're a
hero
this week
valencia got the annie leibovitz
treatment at vogue magazine he really is
the beta orc of ukraine this is real
video uploaded by vogue on instagram
watch
[Music]
it's all pretty insulting to the
thousands of ukrainians who have died
and to the u.s taxpayer who's funding
all of this
but ukraine has gotten away with it
because with the complicity of the
american media they have from day one
waged a fierce information war they lied
about the ghost of kiev they lied about
the island where the troops told the
battleship to eff off
they keep lying now you know they can
lie all they want but why are we still
funding this
todd wood is the founder of cd media is
a former special operations pilot he
joins us tonight todd thanks so much for
coming on so at a certain point when the
president of ukraine and again he's
allowed to worry about his country but
we're also allowed to worry about ours
and when we're funding not simply his
war but his government
and we don't even know where the money's
going and clearly a lot of it's being
stolen when he gives the finger to
american taxpayers by saying your stupid
worries about inflation mean nothing
how masochistic do you have to be to
keep sending this guy money
look thanks for having me back tucker uh
it's an honor um we talked previously
about how corrupt ukraine is and i've
met with a lot of these oligarchs their
only allegiance is to themselves and
their power and their wealth they have
no allegiance to the people of ukraine
kind of like our our oligarch class
right now so this is as you said a huge
scam um you know i i know that all this
money we're sending over there is not
getting to where it's supposed to go
this recent plane crash in greece with a
ukrainian cargo plane uh with the eight
ukrainian crew members who all died and
perished because the plane was loaded
with explosives and and weapons uh
the narrative was it was coming from
serbia to bangladesh but i i find that
extremely hard to believe what i think
is happening is that the weapons are
getting sold and you know this is just a
big grift for either the oligarch class
the defense contractors in the u.s or
maybe biden is sending weapons somewhere
i don't know but
it's not this money is not getting to
where we think it's going that is for
sure
i don't understand how any
responsible person
could send billions in advanced weapon
systems into a war zone and then make no
effort to track what happens to them
next
of course i mean this is uh the huge the
big problem right i mean
this is as i've said before on your show
a
a safe space for criminals to do
whatever they want they want no
accountability and and they have either
pushed too far and because they're now
losing this war and it doesn't matter
how many weapons we send down unless we
send the us military in there i don't
believe ukraine can win this conflict in
any sense of victory that we would see i
think there needs to be some kind of
immediate
negotiated settlement because the
ukrainian people are suffering but
either they have pushed too far and and
now they're getting the push back from
the russian federation which is coming
in massive waves or they want a war with
ukraine which is what i fear and why we
need adult leadership in the white house
yeah and yet everyone in washington fell
for this just like they fell for the
george floyd myth just like they fell
for all the covet lies it's like dumber
people have never run a country todd
wood i appreciate you coming on tonight
thank you anytime thank you tucker
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight